You may have heard that posts Biblical
tradition hails Moses as anxious.
Israel's a first and greatest law giver,
and certainly the Bible depicts Moses as
receiving law from God and conveying it
to the Israelites.
But clearly Moses isn't the author or
compiler of the legal traditions contained
in the Bible. Some of the individual laws
we know, um, are found in very, very,
very ancient near eastern laws.
They're part of an ancient
near eastern legal tradition,
the collections as a whole clearly
date to a much later period of time.
And we're going to see that clearly
when we talk about Deuteronomy today.
And they had been retroed [inaudible]
back to the time of Moses.
But nevertheless,
Moses is the central figure in the
biblical narrative from exodus all the way
through numbers and into Deuteronomy.
And he's going to serve as a paradigm
for Israel's leaders to follow in the
biblical view. No one can look
upon the face of God and live.
And yet Moses who spoke with God,
mouth to mouth the text says,
was an exception to this rule.
So why wasn't he permitted to see
the fulfillment of his labors?
Why was he not permitted
to enter the promised land?
This is a question that
plagued ancient Israel,
and the Bible contains the effort of
tradition to explain this great mystery or
tragedy.
When Moses asked God if he can enter the
land that's in Deuteronomy three 25 God
refuses and he gives his reason.
In Deuteronomy 32 versus 49 to
52 you shall die on the mountain.
The two are about to ascend and shall
be gathered to your kin as your brother
Aaron died on Mount Hoar and was
gathered to his kin for you, Bro,
for you both broke faith with me among
the Israelite people at the waters of
Mary Fatca dish in the Wilderness of sin.
By failing to uphold my sanctity
among the Israelite people,
you may view the land from a distance,
but you shall not enter it the land that
I am giving to the Israelite people.
So what happened at Maryville at
Kadesh that made God so angry? Well,
you can read the story. It's in numbers
20 the incident is described there,
but the answer is still
not entirely clear.
It's not clear what Moses did that was
so bad as to deserve this punishment.
Perhaps it's Moses.
His failure to follow God's instructions
to the letter when he is producing
water, uh, for the Israelites
were demanding water. Perhaps
that's what angers got,
but one gets the impression that the
story in numbers 20 and Deuteronomy
subsequent claim that it was something
about that story that earned Moses God's
disapproval.
You get the impression that these are an
attempt to explain what was probably a
longstanding tradition about a great
leader who died on the east side of the
river. For that to have happened,
for that desk to have happened,
the writers seem to
surmise he must've sinned.
There must've been some
punishment for some sin.
After a very poignant scene in which
God shows Moses the promised land from a
lookout point on the east
side of the Jordan River,
we then read about the death
of Moses in Deuteronomy 34
God spoke to Moses on that same day,
ascend this mount every team,
the peak Nivo in the land
of Moab opposite Jericho.
And look at the land of Canaan,
which I'm giving Israel for a holding.
So Moses went up from the plains of
Moab to mount Nebo to the top of peace,
Pisco opposite Jericho. And God showed
him all the land from Gad to done,
which is in the north and all of
Naphtali and the land of a fry,
em and Menasha and all of Judah in the
south to the outer Mediterranean Sea and
the negative, the southern wilderness
and the plane of the valley of Jericho,
the palm city as far as so are the
end of the Dead Sea. And then Moses,
the servant of God, died there in
the land of Moab, has God had said,
and he buried him in the valley,
in the land of moth.
But no man knows the place
of his burial to this day.
And the people of Israel wept for Moses
in the plains of Moab for 30 days.
And they're never again a rose in Israel,
such a profit as Moses whom God
knew face to face, none like him,
for all the signs and wonders which the
Lord sent him to do in the land of Egypt,
to Pharaoh, to his household, and
to all his land. None like him.
And respect of all the mighty power and
all the great and terrible deeds which
Moses wrought in the sight of all Israel.
There's no other human being in
the Bible who earns such a tribute.
This is unusual for the biblical writer,
uh,
to speak in such glowing
terms of a human character.
And I've said that Moses
becomes a paradigmatic leader
in the biblical tradition
and the force of Moses as paradigmatic
leader of Israel is apparent in the very
first leader to succeed him.
And that is Joshua.
Deuteronomy closes with a transfer
of authority from Moses to Joshua.
So in Deuteronomy 34,
nine,
we read now Joshua son of nun was filled
with the spirit of wisdom because Moses
had laid his hands upon him
and the Israelites heated
him doing as the Lord had
commanded Moses.
And in several ways,
Joshua's going to turn out to be
a kind of carbon copy of Moses.
Moses crosses the Reed Sea.
The waters stand in a heap and the
children of Israel cross over on dry land.
We'll see in connection with Joshua that
he crosses the Jordan river into the
promised land.
The water stand in a heap.
The children of Israel Cross on dry land.
That's in Joshua three,
verse 13. After crossing, um,
the Israelites then celebrate the Passover
and that makes us strong link then to
the exodus led by Moses.
Also at the time of the first Passover,
Moses had a vision of God at the burning
Bush. She was told to remove his shoes,
his sandals,
because he was on holy ground.
Josh was also going to have a theophany.
It's a vision.
After he crosses the Jordan, he'll
see a man with a drawn sword, um,
who's the captain of the Lord's host
and he tells him to remove his shoes.
He is on holy ground.
Moses is the one to mediate a covenant
between God and Israel. At Sinai.
Joshua will mediate every new.
We'll have the covenant at
a place called chef him.
Moses sent out spies
to scout out the land.
Joshua also set out spies
Moses holds out a rod during battle
in order that Israel prevail over her
enemies. And Joshua will
do the same with a javelin.
So these are all important
literary parallels and they
signal the importance of
Moses in Israelite tradition
as the parodic Madec leaders.
So other leaders who are praise
will be modeled on Moses.
It said of Joshua after these rights enter
the promise land. It said on that day,
the Lord Exalted Joshua in the sight of
all Israel so that they revered him all
his days as they had revered Moses.
So no greater praise can be given to an
Israelite leader then to be compared to
Moses.
But now we're going to take a close look
at Deuteronomy and we'll pick up with
Joshua on, um, on Wednesday.
So Israel's wanderings in the
wilderness end on the plains of Moab,
which is on the east
bank of the Jordan River.
And it's there that the book of
Deuteronomy Opens. They are most,
this is going to deliver
three long speeches prior
to the Israelites entry into
the promise land.
And these three speeches constitute
the bulk of the book of Deuteronomy.
Deuteronomy differs very much from the
other four books of the pentitude because
in those books, you'd have an anonymous
narrator who is describing, um,
describes y'all way as directing his
words to Moses to then be conveyed to
Israel. Moses will speak to Israel on
God's behalf, but in Deuteronomy Eight,
Moses is going to speak speaking directly
to the Israelites so that the book is
written almost entirely in
the first person, right?
Whereas the first four books
of the Pentateuch or not,
they're third person
anonymous narrative narration.
Here we have the bulk of the book in
the first person direct speech. Now,
Moshe Weinfeld,
I put his name on the board.
There's someone who you should associate
always with the book of Deuteronomy,
but motion Weinfeld, he's one of
the leading scholars of Deuteronomy.
And he describes the book as expressing
ideology by means of a programmatic
speech put into the
mouth of a great leader.
That's a very common practice and
later Israelite historiography.
And he says it's happening here already.
And I'll be referring quite a
bit to wind fields work. Um,
as we talk about Deuteronomy,
Deuteronomy differs from the other books
of the Pentateuch in other significant
ways. So for example, according to the
priestly writer, Israel received its laws,
its Torah from God at Mount Sinai.
But in Deuteronomy,
the laws were given here on the
plains of morph 40 years after Sinai,
before the Israelites crossed the Jordan,
I'm at Sinai,
the Israelites heard the decalogue, but
the remainder of the laws, it would seem,
are delivered on the plains of Moab.
We can look at the basic structure of
Deuteronomy and a couple of ways we can do
a kind of literary division,
which I have on this side of the
board according to the speeches.
So to begin, we have the first speech,
which is a sort of introductory speech,
and the first four chapters going through
four verse 43 there's an introduction
that gives us the location where the
Israelites are, and also then Moses,
his first sermon, Moses in this
sermon is giving a historical review.
And the purpose of this historical
review is didactic. He wants,
he wants the Israelites
to learn something,
to infer something from this review of
their history from Sinai to the present
day. And in that review, as
he retells the story, um,
which we've just been reading about
in the previous books, we see his,
his selective choice of events.
We see how he's describing things in
a way that underscores God's faithful,
loyal fulfillment of
the covenantal promise.
And he's using this to urge the Israelites
to do their part by obeying God's
laws.
The second speech extends from four
verses 44 through 28 verse six.
And this also contains a bit
of a historical review, again,
retelling some of the narrative of the
earlier books of the Torah. And again,
giving us the insight into this phenomenon
of inner biblical interpretation.
We're parts of the Bible that review
parts elsewhere are already beginning to
interpret and present that
material in a particular light.
But then we have a central section of laws
being presented beginning at about 12,
so this is still part of Moses,
his second speech,
but stretching from
Deuteronomy 12 through 26.
We have laws and this is a in many ways
of repetition of much of the revealed
legislation.
We've already encountered that central
portion of laws 12 through 26 is thought
to be the earliest core of the book.
We're going to come back and
talk about that in a moment. Now,
the Greek title for this book, which is
Deuteronomy Deuteros due to row Namos,
um,
a second law of repetition of the law
and that name derives from the fact that
the bulk of the book contains this legal
core of material which reviews the law
in chapters 27.
We have a covenant renewal ceremony.
It takes place at a
mountain near Schechem. Um,
after the Israelites have crossed the
Jordan that describes the ceremony that
will take place,
excuse me,
after they have crossed the
Jordan and from ancient Greece,
we know that in the ancient world,
settlers who would colonize a place,
particularly if they colonized
a place at divine instigation,
they would perform certain ceremonies
that would be accompanied by blessings and
accompanied by curses. They would
write the laws on stone pillars.
They would erect an altar for sacrifices.
They would proclaim blessings and cursing
purses for those who obey and disobey.
Very similar to what
happens in chapter 27.
All of these elements appear in Chapter
27 Chapter 28 lists the material rewards
that will accrue to Israel
if he is faithful to God's
law and the punishments if
she should disobey in some
of these are very creative,
but the importance of the Deuteronomistic
view of history in which Israel fate
is totally conditioned on her
obedience to the covenant.
This is something that will occupy
us repeatedly at a future date.
I mentioned it here, but it's
something we will need to come back to.
The third speech of Moses
is in chapters 29 and 30.
This speech emphasizes the degree to which
evil fortune is the responsibility of
the community.
Um,
Moses in enumerates additional misfortunes
and sufferings that will be fall
Israel if she sins,
but he emphasizes the choice is Israel's,
you know,
God has been clear regarding
what's required and it's
not beyond Israel's reach
to attain life and prosperity.
She needs to only choose,
and this is all set out and a speech in
chapter 30 I'll read from verses 11 to
20.
Surely this instruction which I enjoy
and upon you this day is not too baffling
for you, nor is it beyond reach. It is
not in the heavens that you should say,
who among us can go up to heavens and
the heavens and get it for us and impart
it to us that we may observe it.
Neither is it beyond the
sea that you should say,
who among us can cross to the other side
of the sea and get it for us and impart
it to us that we may observe it
now the thing is very close to you.
It's in your mouth and in
your heart to observe it. See,
I set before you this day, life and
prosperity, death and adversity.
For I command you this day,
to love the Lord your God,
to walk in his ways and
to keep his commandments,
his laws and his rules that you may
thrive and increase and that the Lord your
God may bless you in the land that
you are about to enter and possess.
Listen to the cadences of of this
kind of language in Deuteronomy,
we haven't heard language
like this before,
but it's what people often think of when
they think of Biblical language starts
here in Deuteronomy.
But if your heart turns away and you give
no heat and are lured into the worship
and the service of other gods,
I declare to you this day that
you shall certainly perish.
You shall not long and do or on the
soil that you are crossing the Jordan to
enter and possess. I call heaven and
earth to witness against you this day.
I have put before you life and death,
blessing and curse.
Choose life if you and your offspring
would live by loving the Lord your God,
hating his commandments
and holding fast to him.
For thereby you shall have life and
shall long and your upon the soil that
you're, that the Lord your God swore
to your ancestors, Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob to give to them.
So all has been given, right.
It's simply Israel
choice to take it or not.
The last section of the book,
chapters 31 to 34 is a sort
of miscellany of appendices.
Um, there's some ancient poetry
that's found in chapter 32,
which is referred to as the song of Moses.
Scholars refer to it as a song of Moses.
Um,
we have the blessings of Moses recorded
in chapter 33 and then chapter 34 is the
story of Moses,
his death.
I read part of that to you
now centuries ago already.
Scholars of the Bible noted that
Deuteronomy opens with the verse.
These are the words that Moses addressed
to all Israel on the other side of the
Jordan. That is to say the Trans
Jordan on the other side of the Jordan.
So that line is obviously written from
the perspective of someone who is inside
the land saying Moses said that when he
was over there outside the land on the
other side of the Jordan. So he's
looking eastward. And so that's aligned,
that one would think,
could not be written by Moses because
Moses did not ever enter the land.
It would not be in a position to talk
about something being on the other side of
the Jordan. Likewise, the last
chapter, which describes Moses,
his death and burial probably
was not written by him.
So as we shall see these and many other
textual features point to the period of
composition for Deuteronomy,
which was many centuries after the time
that Moses would have been supposed to
have lived, um, are if we are to
assume he was a historical character.
And so through careful analysis, you
have scholars like Moesha, widefield,
and Weinfeld.
And many others.
I think Bernard Levinson is the one who
has written about Deuteronomy in your
Jewish Study Bible and that's a
wonderful introduction to read there.
So I encourage you to please
make sure you look at that.
But analysis of scholars like these have
led them to draw the conclusion that
the original core of Deuteronomy
emerged in the eighth century.
And this is now where my,
my interesting little mountain shape
diagram is going to come into play.
It was probably known as a scroll of,
it was probably a skull scroll of laws
known as the book or the scroll of the
Torah.
Um,
Deuteronomy refers to itself that way and
Deuteronomy 17 verses 19 and 20 and so
we think it was probably something roughly
equivalent to chapters 12 to 26 maybe
there was a little introduction,
a little conclusion.
And eventually these laws were put into
the framework of a speech by Moses,
maybe chapters five through 11 and maybe
28 maybe that would have been in the
eighth, seventh century. And
then at some later point,
several things happened and I will
say them in in the following order,
but that doesn't mean they
happened in this order.
We really aren't sure at some
point several things happen.
You have framing chapters,
Deuteronomy one through four,
this sort of introductory
frame and historical review
as well as the appendices
at the end.
Chapters 31 and 34 those get added.
You also have laws being updated,
passages being expanded to
reflect the experience of exile.
You will remember that as
a five 86 the Israelites,
Jerusalem is destroyed and the
Israelites were in exile in Babylonia.
Additionally,
at some point Deuteronomy is appended to
the other four books of the Pentateuch.
Genesis through numbers is
made to proceed this, um,
it's serving therefore as their
conclusion and by being joined to them,
it confers it's title as a book of Torah
as a scroll of Torah to that material
as well.
They don't use the word Torah in that way.
In those books only Deuteronomy,
it uses the word Torah to speak of
God's instruction or revelation overall.
So by being upended now to
genesis through numbers,
all of this perhaps comes
to be known as Tara as well.
And then finally during the exile,
or I'm sorry,
probably during the period after
the exile, um, no during the exile,
but down to the end of the sixth century,
Deuteronomy was incorporated into a
larger narrative history that runs from
Joshua through judges first and
second Samuel First and second kings.
That's all a unit as we'll come
to see in the next lecture.
And so Deuteronomy in a way served as
an introduction to that material looking
forward. So I conclusion
to the previous four books,
but also an introduction
to a long narrative history
that's going to run through
to the end of second kings.
Now there's a lot of debate over the
precise timing of these events in this
process by which this material
grew and was expanded.
But in the post exit period,
at some point, the entire unit,
the genesis through numbers
material, Deuteronomy, um,
and then the lengthy historical narrative
all the way through second kings was
solidified.
The Deuteronomistic history is sort of
an odd conclusion to the genesis through
numbers material because it doesn't
really have the expected narrative climax.
You sort of expect the story to end with
the entry of the Israelites into the
land and hopefully under Moses,
and that doesn't occur.
Some scholars have suggested
that differing Israel's
possession of the land to
the future may have reflected
the historical experience
of exile and experience,
which challenged the very idea of the
possession of the land as central to the
maintenance of the covenant.
So if you are in an exile,
then perhaps the more satisfying ending
is to have Israel not in fact entering
the land.
The complex process by which Deuteronomy
was formed underscores the fact that
modern notions of authorship cannot
be applied to biblical texts.
We think of an author.
We tend to think of an author
as a discrete individual
who composes a text at a
specific time,
but this isn't the way that texts
came into being in the ancient world,
particularly important communal texts.
As Weinfeld points out,
the biblical authors were
what we would call collectors,
compilers,
revisers editors and interpreters
of ancient tradition,
ancient texts for generally the product
of many hands over the stretch of many
long centuries.
And during that time modifications
and recontextualization occurred.
And so we refer to those who transmit
and develop a text in this way as a
school.
But you need to understand that we are
using that in a relatively informal way.
So when we talk about the Deuterenomic
school or the Deuteronomistic school,
we're really talking about the fact that
we have a set of texts that all seem to
share a certain sort of
ideology or orientation.
And yet we know that parts of them seem
to date from very, very different times.
And so we think of that
text is being preserved,
transmitted and developed by many hands,
um,
who share certain commonalities, common
ideology. So we call it a school.
It's not that we know of the existence
of the Deuteronomistic school and we say,
Oh, well then they must have produced
this text. It's the other way around.
We have a text and it's features suggest
to us a longstanding tradition of
scholarship, right, that preserved
and transmitted the texts in that way.
Same with the priestly school.
We're speaking about the priests,
the materials which clearly have
evidence of originating from the eighth,
seventh, sixth and fifth centuries. And
so there must have been a common, um, uh,
uh,
stretch of scholarship that would have
preserved and transmitted in a developed
those traditions.
And we call that the priestly school,
the legal corps of Deuteronomy.
So really from five to 26,
because five is where some of the legal
material begins, contains first of all,
a somewhat expanded version
of the 10 Commandments.
You have that in Deuteronomy five and
then other laws really from 12 to 26 that
resemble the legal material
that's found in exodus, the,
the collection of material
we've called the Covenant Code.
And they also seem to bear some
relationship to the laws in Leviticus and
numbers.
But the question is what
is the relationship between
the different versions of
the legal material?
Some of these laws will parallel each
other's each other quite closely and
others do not.
So our Deuteronomy is legal traditions,
a direct response to or modification of
the laws and exodus and numbers or are
they best understood as um,
just different independent formulations
of a common legal tradition.
Um,
Weinfeld has argued that Deuteronomy is
dependent on the previous traditions of
the pentitude tuk that Deuteronomy
revises and reforms them according to new
ideas. It's new notion of a
centralized cultic worship.
And secondly,
it's a humanitarian spirit.
Those are too controlling ideologies.
He says its shape,
its revision of preexisting material.
He's specifically argues that
Deuteronomy is dependent on the e source.
The source at some scholars think is
pretty hard to isolate or find in the
biblical text, but in East
Sinai's referred to as Horeb and,
and Deuteronomy Sinai is also horrible.
So the author of Deuteronomy limits the
revelation at Sinai to the deck log and
seems to assert that the full law was
given to Moses for the Israelites on the
plains of Moab and Weinfeld view.
This means that Deuteronomy,
with its revisions,
what have been seen would have been
presented as and would've been seen as an
updated replacement of the old book of
the Covenant rather than its compliment.
It exists side by side in our text now.
But I think in his view,
those who promulgated it,
we're understanding it as the updated
replacement of the laws of the,
of the book of the Covenant.
For the most part,
Deuteronomy doesn't really contain
much in the way of civil law.
It tends to focus on the moral religious
prescriptions, kind of the APP,
addictive law in Israel.
And the few civil laws that are there
tend to be reworked in line with
Deuteronomy humanity. So for
example, the laws of the ties,
the laws or the seventh
year release of debts,
the rules for the release of slaves,
the rules for the three festivals,
these are all ancient laws. They
occur an exodus, but they appear.
And Deuteronomy with modifications,
modifications about things that
concern the Deuteronomistic.
And some of you have discussed some of
these in section. So in Deuteronomy,
the Israelite debt slave comes
out of his or her servitude. Um,
with generous gifts from the owner.
This is not something that appears
in exodus or as another example.
Deuteronomy extends the Covenant Codes,
Prohibition Against Afflicting and
resident alien. In Deuteronomy,
there's the insistence at these are lights
must not just refrain from afflicting
them but must love the resident alien.
It goes so far as to provide
concrete legal benefits, um,
food and so on for the resident alien.
So while the relationship of d to some
of the laws and the Covenant Code is
often not always,
but often one of revision,
the relationship between d and the
laws and the priestly source is more
difficult to characterize.
The priestly source seems to represent
an equally early set of laws,
a legal traditions that just emanated
from a very different circle and had
different concerns.
It tends to deal with sacral topics or
if it's dealing with other topics that
we'll deal with.
The sacral implications of those topics
like d p often updates and revises laws
of the Covenant Code.
We can see that in the fact
that the priestly source
abolishes is relight dates,
debt slavery altogether and insists that
slaves must be acquired only from the
nations around Israel. And that was where
like Ken and enslave another Israelite.
Nevertheless,
Weinfeld argues that on
occasion Deuteronomy contains
laws that are also found
in p but presents them in a more
rational manner is the word he uses or d
sacralizing manner.
So Ds treatment and Deuteronomy
is treatment of sacrifice.
We'll see in a moment is going to be
different. For example, from peas,
they have different concerns and different
Fokai in their presentation of that
material.
In any event,
many scholars through their analysis of
these texts have been led to conclude
that the Deuteronomistic school
updated and revised earlier laws,
particularly laws in the Covenant Code,
but sometimes also in the
older legal straight of of p.
And they did so in keeping
with the circumstances of
the eighth to sixth century.
So Deuteronomy exemplifies a phenomenon
that occurs at several critical
junctures in Israel's history and we're
going to see this as we move forward
through the biblical text.
And that is the modification.
And rewriting of earlier
laws and traditions in the
light of new circumstances
and ideas.
So don't.
Deuteronomy is itself and implicit
authorization of the process of
interpretation and the notion of Canon
or sacred Canon that's exemplified then
by biblical texts is one that allows for
continued unfolding and development of
the sacred tradition.
And that's an idea that I think differs
very much from modern intuitions about
the nature of secret cannons.
I think a lot of people have the intuition
that a sacred Canon means that the
text is fixed, static and authoritative
because it is fixed and static.
We're unchanging.
That's not the biblical view or ancient
view of sacred Canon texts represents
representing sacred
revelation were modified,
they were revised, they were
rephrased, they were updated,
and they were interpreted in the process
of transmission and preservation.
It was precisely because
a text or a tradition was
sacred and authoritative that
it was important that it adapt
and speak to new circumstances.
Otherwise it would
appear to be irrelevant.
So it's a very different notion of what
it means for something to be canonical
and sacred from what I think some moderns
have come to understand those terms to
mean.
So what are the special circumstances
and concerns that guide Deuteronomy is
revisions, uh, of tradition.
One of the primary changes you've probably
heard in section as well by now is
the emphasis on worship at a single
central shrine that's going to represent a
great change in Israel's religious
practice. According to Deuteronomy,
the central sanctuary will be located
in a place that God himself will choose.
It's not named and Deuteronomy or in a
place where he will cause his name to
dwell.
That's the other phrase that's used.
Jerusalem has never explicitly
mentioned as the site in question,
but Jerusalem will later in fact
fulfill this function according to other
biblical texts.
Now there are striking
similarities between Deuteronomy
is religious program and
the major religious reforms that were
carried out in the eighth century by King
Hezekiah.
But even more so,
I'm in the seventh century by the
King Josiah around six 22 king Josiah.
This is a reform that's reported in the
book of Second Kings and second kings
22. Um, this reform, um,
has long been noticed and
provides scholars with the
basis for dating the core
materials of Deuteronomy,
dating them to the late seventh century.
According to the story in second kings
during temple repairs that were being
done in the time of King
Josiah, the scroll of the
Torah. That's how it's phrased.
The scroll of the Torah was
found and when it was read,
the king was distressed because its
requirements were not being upheld.
Now this term, the scroll
of the Torah, as I said,
does not occur in genesis through number.
It is a phrase that occurs in
Deuteronomy, Deuteronomy 17. Um,
then continuing the content,
the account in second kings,
Josiah said to take action.
He assembles the people.
He publicly reads the scroll,
the people agree to its terms
and then Josiah's reforms begin.
We hear that he purges the
temple of vessels that had
been made for bow and ashy
Ra that were in the temple of Yahweh.
He removes all foreign
elements from the cult.
He prohibits sacrifice to Yahweh anywhere,
but in the central sanctuary,
he destroys all of the high places.
This refers to sort of rural shrines
that were scattered throughout the
countryside were local priests and
Levites might offer sacrifices for people,
ritual, shrines and pillars being
used in the worship of your way.
These are deemed to be quite
legitimate in theJ and e's sources.
The patriarchs are doing this
sort of thing all the time,
building altars all around the country,
but it's Deuteronomy that contains
commandments to destroy the worship.
First of all,
the worship of other gods,
but I'll should also the worship of
Yahweh in high places or in rural shrines.
So this is evidence again that what
Josiah found a basis reforms on was
something like the book of Deuteronomy.
It's Deuteronomy that contains the
prohibitions of of high places and so on.
After these reforms, it's reported
that the Passover was celebrated.
It was celebrated not as a family
observance in individual homes.
It was celebrated as
a national pilgrimage.
Festivals celebrated by
everyone in Jerusalem.
That's how its celebration has described
in the book of Deuteronomy is described
as a family celebration and an individual
homes and the other books of the Bible.
So again,
this is another basis for the conclusion
that the scroll of the law found by
Josiah and guiding has reforms,
was something like the
legal corps of Deuteronomy.
Scholars now think that that legal
corps of Deuteronomy was produced in the
northern kingdom,
the northern kingdom of Israel,
which fell and seven 22 you'll recall
it was probably produced there in the
eighth century.
And that is supported by the fact that
Deuteronomy has affinities with some
profits,
with the writings of some profits we'll
be looking at later from the northern
Kingdom of the eighth century,
such as the Prophet Hosea.
And we'll see this when we
look at Jose, his writings. Um,
it also has affinities with the source,
which is also connected
with the northern kingdom.
In the ninth and eighth
century, the northern kingdom
was the site of a struggle,
a struggle against Baal worship.
It was also home to certain profits such
as Elijah and Elisha who are known for
their zealotry. And they're
exclusive. Yeah. Wisdom.
So some scholars think that was going
on in the ninth, eighth century,
in the north. This sort of Ya'll way
only party. Um, that was, um, uh,
you know, working hard and
struggling against Baal worship.
And they think that those Yahweh only
traditions were brought south after the
fall of the northern Kingdom and seven 22,
yet refugees coming south.
They brought these traditions with them.
Um,
some of these written materials
were put into the temple.
And then about a century later during
design as time when the temple is being
refurbished, they were found, um,
possibly this material was then
worked into a larger scroll, um,
given it's mosaic introductions and so
on. And uh, that all contributed to,
um,
Josiah's reform.
So the centralization of the cult also
needs to be understood against the larger
political backdrop of
the late seventh century.
The Assyrian threat loomed large.
You have to remember that the northern
kingdom has already been completely
destroyed. 10 tribes, exile,
deported and essentially
lost the southern kingdom,
managed to escape destruction, but only
by paying tribute as a vassal to a,
so Judah,
the southern kingdom is a tribute paying
vassal state to the Assyrian overlord.
And of course there's a great deal of a
Syrian cultural influence and religious
influence in Judah as a result.
So second kings tells us that there
were foreign forms of worship being
introduced right into the temple. Josiah's
reforms have been interpreted by some,
as an attempt to assert the political and
the cultural and religious autonomy of
Judah.
Unregulated worship throughout the land
was no longer going to be an acceptable,
the people we're going to be United around
a central standardized, yeah way cult,
which would be purged them, any Syrian
influence or foreign influence, um,
and this was deemed as necessary to stand
up against or to survive the Assyrian
threat.
So it's in that context that we can look
at the very strong parallels that exist
between the book of Deuteronomy and
certain a Syrian treaties from the seventh
century. We already talked about, um,
the Hittite a vassal treaties as a model
for the Israelite Covenant when we were
talking about exodus.
But Deuteronomy is clearly dependent on
another model and that is the Assyrian
Vassal Treaty.
The best exemplars of these treaties
are the treaties of the Assyrian.
Emperor Esther hadn't,
he was a seventh century, um, ruler
of a Syria down to about six 69.
These treaties were discovered
about 50 years ago. Um,
and Moshe Weinfeld is one of the people
who has done a tremendous amount of work
with these treaties and he's argued at
great length that Deuteronomy reworks the
second millennium Hittite
model in accordance with
the covenantal patterns that
are evident in the first millennium
vassal treaties of Esarhaddon.
We see history being used as a
motivational tool and we see laws being
reinforced by curses.
Um,
and it's fascinating if you line up
some of the curses in Esarhaddon,
it's treaties with the curses
and Deuteronomy. There's
an amazing correspondence.
Um, Deuteronomy also includes blessings.
The Assyrians didn't do that. Um,
Weinfeld notes that the Assyrian treaties
are really loyalty oaths that are
imposed upon vassals
rather than true covenants.
And Deuteronomy is also
something of a low loyalty oath,
except that the people are pledging
their loyalty to a god rather than to a
human king. So you have the x rotation
to love the Lord your God. I mean,
think back to some of that language that
we heard is I read Deuteronomy 30 the
exhortation to love the Lord your
God, to go after God, to fear God,
to listen to the voice of God.
These are all typical of pledges of
loyalty and they're paralleled in the
Assyrian treaties where the vassal
has to love the crown prince.
He has to listen to the voice of the crown
prince. The same phrasiology are used.
So it is a political literary form,
but it's borrowed and it's referred
to God the Assyrian Gds. Also,
we'll warn against profits or ecstatics
or dream interpreters who will try to
foment sedition.
If you'll notice in Deuteronomy 13,
we have something quite similar,
a warning against false prophets
who will try to foment sedition,
lead the people to the
worship of other gods.
Some scholars refer to Deuteronomy as
a kind of counter treaty if you will,
right? A subversive document that's trying
to shift the people's loyalty from the
Assyrian overlord,
right to God,
the true sovereign right and
it's part of a national movement.
Deuteronomy differs in style,
in terminology,
in outlook and in theological assumptions
from the other books of the Torah as a
series of public speeches. It adopts
a highly rhetorical tone, very,
um, sometimes on almost artificial style.
It's the style of a very skilled, um,
preacher almost. Um, he,
it employs direct address you
use sometimes in a singular,
sometimes in the plural,
but Moses is constantly speaking in
a very personal tone, direct address.
And there are all sorts of hortatory
phrases, phrases that x hort you, um,
to do this with all your heart and soul.
Do this in order that it
may go well with you. I'm,
the land is described as a
land where milk and honey flow.
And if only you will obey the
voice of Yahweh, your God.
And this is the kind of language that's
used here and not so much in the other
books.
So let's isolate now some of the major
themes of Deuteronomy before we close our
study of the pentitude. First
of all, if I, as I've mentioned,
the centralization of the cult, that's
a key theme in the book of Deuteronomy.
And I had very important effects.
It brought Judy and religion closer
to monotheism because you have the
insistence of I'm worshiping one God in
his one central sanctuary sacrifice was
offered only on pilgrimage to Jerusalem,
which meant that slaughter of animals
for meat in the countryside no longer has
a sacred component to it. It's just
ordinary, common profane slaughter. Um,
there's evidence that that wasn't true
before this reform that if you wanted to
kill an animal for me, you kind of kind
of a make shift alter out there in the,
in the field. Um, and you
would pour out the blood and,
and give it back to God and so on. You
might still pour out the blood obviously,
but there was previously a
more sacred element to it.
Now slaughter in the countryside
was simply common profane slaughter.
As a result, you have a lot of
rural Levi's were out of business.
Now a lot of people who would
have officiated at local
shrines and they are out
of business,
that probably explains the
fact that Deuteronomy makes
special provision for the
Levi's send includes them in
it's uh, in legislation, um,
sort of social welfare legislation.
There are provisions that are made for
the Levi's who are not going to be able
to earn their income anymore.
These local shrines.
So many of them would have gone up to
Jerusalem and real tensions going to
develop between the Jerusalem
priests and this class of Levi's, um,
who are newcomers and we'll see some of
that tension played out in some other
texts. So centralization of the cult
and that has some social ramifications.
We also have the, a sort of a
greater abstraction of the deity.
Is this something many people pointed
to in the book of Deuteronomy because
Deuteronomy and books
that are related to it,
those that are going to
follow consistently refer to
the sanctuary as the place
where Yahweh chose to
cause his name to dwell.
God isn't said to God himself,
isn't said to dwell in the temple,
nor is the temple described
as a house of God.
The temple is always the dwelling of his
name. The house is built for his name.
Weinfeld asserts that this is in order
to combat the ancient to popular belief
that God actually dwells in the sanctuary.
Likewise to eradicate or guard against
the idea which is implicit in earlier
sources that God sits enthroned
on the the, on the crew team,
on the chair of beam who guard has arc.
Deuteronomy emphasizes that the function
of the arc is exclusively to how's the
tablets, the tablets of the covenant.
That's its purpose. They are,
cover isn't mentioned.
The Cherubim aren't mentioned.
We don't have the image of
this as a throne with the
archis God's footstool. Um,
so it seems to be a greater
abstraction of the deity. Um,
some abstraction is also apparent in
the shift from visual to oral imagery in
describing God's self
manifestations or theophanous.
One hears God but one doesn't
see God in Deuteronomy.
And that's very different from earlier
texts where we're seeing a sort of a
cloud in case fire and so on.
So the sanctuary is understood to be a
house of worship as much as it is how a a
cultic center in which is what lights
and foreigners alike may deliver prayers
to God who dwells in heaven. So he is
in heaven. This is a place of worship.
That's not to say that
sacrifices abolished,
it's not to say the sacrifice isn't
important to Deuteronomy very far from it.
It's an essential part of
God's service for Deuteronomy.
But Deuteronomy is less interested
in cultic matters. And in any event,
it focuses on when it
focuses on sacrifices,
it focuses on a different
aspect of those sacrifices.
The sacrifices it talks about consists
primarily of offerings that are consumed
by the offer in the sanctuary
or are shared with the
disenfranchised in some way.
The leave Eit, uh, the
alien resident, the orphan,
the widow portions are given to them.
So by emphasizing the obligation
to share the sacrificial meal with
disadvantaged members of
society, Deuteronomy, uh,
almost gives the impression that the
primary purpose of the sacrifices is
humanitarian or at least personal,
the fulfillment of a religious obligation
or the expression of gratitude to God
and so on.
These are aspects of the sacrifices
that are emphasized in Deuteronomy.
Deuteronomy also emphasizes social
justice and personal ethics and neighborly
responsibility.
God's own righteous behavior
on behalf of the week.
And the oppressed is a model
for Israel's righteous behavior.
God assists the orphan,
the widow and the stranger,
and that's the basis of Israel's
a injunction to assist them. Also,
it's the basis for the humanitarianism
that I mentioned earlier that seems to
run through the laws of Deuteronomy
12 through 26. Uh, further theme.
And Deuteronomy is the fact
that the covenant concept
entails the idea that each
generation of Israelites understand itself
as having been bound with God in the
original covenant. So in Deuteronomy
five versus two to three,
the Lord our God made a
covenant with us at Horeb Sinai.
It was not with our fathers that the
Lord made this covenant, but with us,
the living,
every one of us who is here today.
Now this is interesting because
remember this is a generation.
The generation has died off that
saw the exodus and Sinai, right?
So these are the children now and
they're saying, no, it was with us.
Every one of us who is here today.
So every generation of Israel is to
view itself as standing at the Sacred
Mountain to conclude a covenant with God.
And that decisive moment
has to be made ever present.
That's a process that's facilitated
by the obligation to study,
to study the laws, to recite them
daily, to teach them to your children.
These are instructions that are
contained in Deuteronomy. Moreover,
Deuteronomy 31 proclaims
that every seventh year the
Tara is to be read publicly
the entire thing. And
Weinfeld argues that, uh,
where many ancient near eastern cultures
direct the king to write the laws for
himself to read them.
It's only in Israel.
He's yet to find a parallel is only in
Israel that the law is a manual for both
the king and the people is
to be proclaimed and metal
out to the people on a
regular basis every seven years.
Further theme of Deuteronomy
is the emphasis on love.
Weinfeld points out that the Assyrian
treaties stress the vassals love for the
crown prince,
but there's never a reciprocal love
by the crown prince for the vassal and
Deuteronomy differs in this respect.
Deuteronomy emphasizes God's gracious
and undeserved love of Israel and that's
expressed in his mighty
acts on Israel's behalf.
The deuteronomist makes it clear
that God's great love should awaken a
reciprocal love on Israel's
part love of God, love of God.
Here it really means a loyalty.
The word that is used as a word
that stresses loyalty, love,
and loyalty are mere abstractions.
However,
without some sort of vehicle for their
expression and the vehicle for the
expression then is God's Torah,
the sum total of God's and instructions
and laws and guidelines which are
supposed to ensure long life
and prosperity in the land.
That idea is found in a very
important passage known as the Schema.
This is a passage that's really a
central expression of the love of God in
Israel,
and it's been singled out as an essential
part of the Jewish liturgy at a very
early,
early stage and continues to this day.
It's a so-called because of
the first word of the passage.
It's in Deuteronomy six it begins in
verse four and the first word is here.
Shema, hear, oh, Israel.
Yeah. Hawaii is our God.
Yahweh alone.
You shall love the Lord your God with
all your heart and with all your soul and
with all your might take to heart these
instructions with which I charge you
this day.
Impress them upon your children.
Recite them when you stay at home and
when you are away, when you lie down,
and when you get up,
buying them as a sign on your hand
and let them serve as a symbol on your
forehead and scribe them on the doorposts
of your house and on your gates.
So love and loyalty is to,
God is the foundation of the Tara.
But Tara is the fulfillment
of this love and loyalty,
studying it and observing it and
teaching it and transmitting it.
Another key idea that occurs
in Deuteronomy is the idea
of Israel as the chosen
people.
This is what we've,
we find it here for the first time.
Um,
it's an expression of the particularity
of Israel and its unique relationship
with God and that uniqueness is expressed
by this term [inaudible] which means
to elect or to choose.
This is the first time we encounter this.
Yahweh has chosen Israel in an act of
freely bestowed grace and love to be his
special property.
Deuteronomy 10 verse 14 Mark The heavens
to their utter most reaches belong to
the Lord, your God, the earth
and all of that is on it.
Yet it was to your fathers that the Lord
was drawn in his love for them so that
he chose you are lineal descendants from
among all peoples as is now the case.
This idea may be rooted in the ancient,
near each in ancient near eastern
political sphere in which sovereigns would
single out vassals for the status
of special property. In effect,
the word used is a word
we do find an exodus,
but Deuteronomy contains
statements of National Pride, um,
national exaltation.
And unlike the priestly materials which
portray holiness as a future goal to be
attained through the
observance of God's Torah,
you shall be holy to me by
doing the following things.
Deuteronomy speaks of Israel as holy
now and thus bound to the observance of
God's Torah because of their holiness.
You are a holy people to me.
Therefore you should do so to put it,
and this is perhaps to put it too
crudely for p for the priestly source,
holiness is a goal to be attained
through obedience to God's Torah.
For Deuteronomy,
holiness is a status to be lost
through disobedience to God's Torah.
When we come back,
I just want to finish up with one or
two last comments about a couple of key
ideas or themes.
And before we move on to the beginning
of the Deuteronomistic history that
starts in Joshua, this coming
week you'll be having, um,
midterms as part of your section meeting.
And in addition, at 6:00 PM tonight,
I'll be making the essay
question available online
and if it gets to six oh one
and there's nothing online,
somebody called me real fast. Okay.
All right, good. Thanks. Then good
luck with the, with the exams.